boxing you're gonna go out there and
really back it up you know how to go out
there and you ever watch something there
the older fighters fight like in 30 to
40 to 50 oh not that far back i watch
what you're doing around with if I have
watched your adversity amazing let me go
see if I am what's up everybody welcome
to another episode of hot boxing I'm
Evan burr and I'm Mike Tyson like we got
it [ __ ] young phenom baby Willard
welcome brother
yes spit forth before this is over spit
for you before I saw ya that's what you
do I might ride I'm gonna try to have
something ready for y'all okay okay top
of the dome and if you don't marinate
all the greats go listen nice and I'm
great what he cuts it abuser got case a
of a great man I commend it striking
yeah Mike you look like [ __ ] shafted a
dog I feel look good yeah you got that
energy bro well Damian man it's great to
have you here so what are you doing in
town we play the Lakers tomorrow so
usually when we got a rural game we
travel today before to give ourselves a
chance there's my wife and his
girlfriend they're troublemakers yeah we
traveled today before it play the Lakers
tomorrow just got in today yeah we are
literally just landed in Camarillo
wow it's a little different cuz in the
NFL there's no way I could have done
that
is that clean DNA well it's like you got
to go to the hotel walk down I mean I
got a lot more people to keep keep track
we 15 players on a run
so that's true well really tough week
for basketball yeah I mean this city
lost one of its legends one of his
favorite people Kobe Bryant yeah I mean
I was deeply affected by it as were
millions of people how how is it hit you
brother I mean it hit hard
I think I'm from California so growing
up in Oakland Golden State they never
made the playoffs so when the playoffs
came around I transformed into a Lakers
fan and Kobe and Shaq and Robert Horry
all those dudes you know when they went
on that run you know I was at a half
warrior have Laker fan so growing up
making it to the NBA and I I grew up
idolizing Kobe and I was a fan of Kobe
and then make it to the NBA and become a
peer is and you know I played my first
NBA game against Kobe and then my first
all-star game I sat on the bench with
him the whole time and became friends
with Kobe so I think all of those things
being in touch with him and from so many
different lenses it just it said you
know I don't really know what else to
say about it this is so disturbing and
so shocking yeah that you just really
don't know what to think of it you know
you know tomorrow is definitely gonna be
a tough day for for the basketball
community and everybody who came in
contact with yeah I mean he just meant
so much yeah it was crazy man just like
I'm not I grew up watching basketball
because my dad is basketball player he
played d1 Jacksonville University in
Florida so I always watched the watch
basketball grew up in LA for the most
part
so obviously Kobe was always a fixture
but to me he was like the definition of
a leader yeah as an athlete you know
wanted to take that role too
yeah he wanted to take that Rosalita
yeah so you know
for me it was like just thinking about
the whole thing it was crazy enough to
have a guy like that here one day gone
down the neck but you know we you know
we're just morning right now because
that's that's the natural thing to do
but the reality we're all going down
that path the life that we all want to
face that journey you know it's just
what we do here what we leave behind our
journey is really what counts there's
not really what I'm talking I having the
fame and fortune and stuff no Colby's
different he's an international store
but just I'm leaving here knowing that
you were kind to people on people to say
what the kind person he was a good
person
and you gave him the best you had you
gave life the best you had yeah you
didn't leave anything lift it all over
you left this all on the concrete you
know your hold anything back person you
know life is just preparing and
preparing you for death that's what life
is very much a blueprint to death yeah
you know we talk about that a lot you
know and also to me it's you know and
when a guy like Kobe goes and in that
type of situation it's a it's a wake-up
call to everybody you know but you got
to live this you get one shot here man
in life exactly you got to live this
life to the greatest extent that you
possibly can it's your duty as the
living toneri the burden of war that's
what we have to figure how do you live
your life the best possible way hey
listen it appears we don't know I'm
personal like that we weren't there but
it appeared he was living his life the
perfect way and if that appears we had
the appearance right right you know this
tells us that life is very short but
even more so than that it's very
unpredictable yeah you know yeah very
unpredictable and I think some sign like
this week it's all won't even though
with if we learnt even intend to learn
this dissolved the system because we're
all different after now I'm a different
person now since that happened yeah and
I don't even know what happened but I'm
different
do you know I mean I don't know you you
know exactly
but I don't even know how I'm different
but I'm different now that happened yeah
you know I showed I'd like to believe
I'm ugh I have more gratitude which I'm
grateful for my existence in the air
that I breathe and for my family and
sometimes I think you know I get cocky
sometimes I think I can get a lot of
people a lot of broads and I guess
sometimes I guess I just need to be more
have more gratitude mm-hmm yeah always
well for me I forget about gratitude
sometimes yeah
constant reminder you just grateful to
see another day absolutely no it's
breathe if airing in love it's like yeah
well rest in peace to Coby and Gigi and
all the families involved you know it's
just absolutely heartbreaking you know
everyone's with you guys you know our
thoughts and prayers out of everyone so
the Dean you're a huge fighting fan too
on the side how do you thought when you
start doing this stuff when I was I want
to say when I was about eight or nine I
used my family used to have big fight
parties there was yo fights all the way
to like Oscar De La Hoya fights and then
Floyd fights it was always like the the
big pay-per-view fights and then when I
got to like high school I just started
to learn more about all the fighters you
know me the guys that weren't prize
fighters and big-name fighters and then
I got interested in like people's
stories and watching who was calling out
who and watching people train and
watching press conferences and who was
gonna back up what they said they was
gonna do and who was they were to stay
focused and who wanted to fight the best
I just kind of got attached to that
through the city college yeah I just and
fight and I think this is different
because it's like is one-on-one
yes in basketball I could get into it
with somebody and my team was gonna play
a team and there's gonna be a matchup
like within the team but
combat sports is like yeah we gotta
fight each other that's different than
than anything so I've always been like
really interested and I really respect
the fact that like like the confidence
and just the way fighters speak and that
what they got to go through the train
and get ready for a fight and get in the
ring and fight in front of millions of
people like you can get knocked out and
hurt and from me like your family your
kids and I've always just had a lot of
love and respect for that so as I've
gotten older I just I just watch it
harder and harder and harder and not
pretty much I mean it's hundreds of
Fighters that I type their name in on
youtube and watch them train watch the
interviews like train recently I watched
a lot of Andy Ruiz just because I was
familiar with him before the first
Joshua fight on because I came across on
his fights before just watching random
fights on TV and then I started to watch
him train I watched Andy Ruiz I watched
like I said earlier the Charro's a lot
of the younger fighters I like to follow
them and just see how they train and if
they like able to be consistent and if
they keep that same passion Devon Haney
Ryan Garcia Shakur Stephenson Sheik was
really good
just a lot of a lot of dudes like that I
mean the top fighters I'm in shock I
catch all these stuff Willie Monroe
Wilder I think water is like really
interesting cuz like you and I first
went the first time I ever saw him fight
like he's like the one that I can see
the most like Grover Overman is
interesting he didn't pull the line
there so like Wilder big baby Miller
Anthony jar it's like just Regis
pro-grade I mean I've your [ __ ]
student dude
not really watch yeah every single day
is there do you feel like there are
things that you learn about the
psychology of Fighters or
strategies or whatever it might be that
you apply in your basketball game um I
wouldn't say on things that I apply
mm-hmm because I just think is fighting
is just so different
yeah like this far is like what you have
to prepare to go into like I said
earlier I'm not going through my games
but panting it was more like it for a
real war yeah boxing you got to go out
there and really back it up
you know how to go out there you ever
watch thing they're the older fighters
fight like in the 30 to 40 to 50 oh not
that far back I watch what she doing
Robinson if I have watched her grave
robbers he amazing
let me talk to you about great fancy um
I'm listen right Robinson had 40 fight
to 848 oh and then he lost one fight
right and after he lost that one fight
he went 80 fights undefeated you know so
he was like a hundred so director was
like a hundred and seventy-four and one
right
and I ran what 85 knockout you know
listen you get a guy like Andy Armstrong
way he defended his welterweight title
20 times in two years five times in one
month that's crazy
more than a fight a week it's a mom he's
a monster
there's some monsters in the past you
know they put people like me and check
they put our egos in check when you
think you know I took this is the
baddest man the planet the greatest
fighters are created and then I look in
the history books nothing off [ __ ] I'm
just talking [ __ ] yeah I watched it
wasn't even that long ago like a month
ago I watched I think it was Jack
Johnson they got us like a 45 minute
long video on YouTube yeah a documentary
where he got a fight aid he fighting
outside and it's like 35 or 45 rounds or
something yeah
and he beat up the dude for like 25
rounds and it's hot outside and he ended
up losing but it's like that's like dem
type conditions and what it was for them
back then it's similar to what you're
saying with how like what they did
compared to what fighters do now and
it's like you respect it on it this love
I don't put myself in the league
objective Jack Johnson fighting in the
ring and there's 75,000 of people saying
I might kill you and negative you her
don't I'm gonna kill your wife am I hang
up [ __ ] was on guitar and feathered a
[ __ ] because she's white you know this
is what they think this is what they're
saying in the wall these try you know
what he's doing
oh oh he's so beautiful I want Emerson
to you tonight and he's talking to the
guy's wife how you doing miss Jeffries
hey Johnny so mr. Selden how you doing
sir the Popo beat the guy back and watch
what you see if you ever watch him fight
you look he's licking the car though
he's smiling could there curse smelling
like a dog Wow [ __ ] you're gonna get
the document he made my cry you're such
a tough guy that's why I only got his
courage from he really he was Jack
Johnson document he said I'm nothing
compared to Jack Johnson Jack Johnson
listen you listen in 1908
you got you got lynched for looking at
way with me reckless eyeballin he
married three of them good for him and
it was cheating I want him so much than
she committed suicide he took me then I
got arrested for pimping in the pimp in
charge the man asked what was this this
isn't like I mean was a they put it on
them I think in 1909 Wow dad didn't
escape the country left the country
where'd he go in Europe for a while and
then he lost the title to the gym Jeff I
know just woolen and Cuba then he made a
deal with the government he came back
and did a year in a month and in
Leavenworth Penitentiary
well David he heard of Tom Molineux
[Music]
[Music]